c'était un homme inconnu qui a gouverné le
monde pendant un certain temps il était une sorte de
marionnettiste dans l'administration Bush
qu'il était la principale force derrière
la guerre en Irak mais qu'il était
vraiment l'homme de l'ombre
[  Musique]
ces politiques ont conduit à des centaines de
milliers de morts dans ce que l'on voit
maintenant et ont vraiment été vues à l'époque, mais seuls les
gens ont été induits en erreur dans une guerre très contraire à l'éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle lui a vraiment insufflé de l'ambition
mais il plaisante très  beaucoup sur la façon dont
quiconque aurait épousé Lynne, sa femme,
serait devenu vice-président et il lui en
attribue le mérite, vous savez
sans elle, il aurait probablement été
très heureux de mentir,
vous savez, de travailler, de boire et de
se battre, nous n'aurions probablement
jamais  si la guerre en Irak
avait toujours été comparée à Vader Dark Vador,
je connais exactement le personnage le plus
léger auquel vous pourriez être comparé
et il a beaucoup apprécié que vous sachiez qu'il
se déguiserait en Vader, etc. Je suis
s  ure ed fallin est bien pensé si on
va parler de Star Wars
autant inviter Dark Vador
je suis content d'accepter
[Musique]
tu dors bien la nuit je serai sourd non
je veux dire de manière sérieuse tu sais  en
ce qui concerne le genre de culpabilité que les
démons viennent il prétend non il prétend que
tu ne regardes pas en arrière tu sais que tu fais un
choix c'est tout tu fais avec
tu sais mais je sais juste que je me demande juste
si quelqu'un est capable de faire  que sans
être hanté par vous savez l'incroyable
drame qui se déroule car si ses idées